we're going to be talking to the super
uber talented Maggie
enter Rios you guys need to check her
out right now on Instagram on the
instagrams old little patterns this is
Maggie she's super cool she's super fun
and here's some of her work
so cool I don't want to find out about
how she does is is she using reference
are there digital pens involved or this
digital inking pens maybe it's not all
analog maybe it's a little bit digital
and here are some facts that you need to
know about her she's a botanical
illustrator some of her clients include
Apple Crayola Instagram Sephora and DSW
the shoe company she's also been
featured on a Today Show segment called
things we love in 2017 let's take a look
at some of her work okay talk to us
about your process how are you doing
this like where does this come from
this piece I did for a demo that I was
doing at Apple in Chicago was doing like
an illustration and I was at home I was
buying a cable it's a little different
proprietary did this and then but it was
for the purpose of showing the start to
finish in the capability of her grade
what I like about this piece is I did it
really cleanly because I knew I was
being recorded yeah so this is this is
pretty typical of my color illustration
work so it's all done digitally raster I
definitely would not do vector for
something like this yeah okay so you're
doing this thing are you doing a sketch
first like do you use reference for the
ampersand I just kind of wanted to
create like an ampersand I had never
seen before so I just kept playing
around the shapes I didn't really follow
any rules which I probably broke a few
but I dig it and then for the flowers I
do occasionally use reference but for
this particular piece I chose to sort of
make out flowers unless I'm working on
like a fragrance line that they have
like really specific things they need
included it's much more well I would say
it's more streamlined for me to not be
following strict rules so maybe I'll
take like the shape of an existing
flower and then look at it
minutes draw something similar and then
start filling it in with maybe
fantastical or whimsical details that
don't necessarily exist no that's bad I
also find that that makes my work look
way more unique than if it was just you
know clipart flower style right there's
definitely a lot of imagination woven in
there as well a lot of you guys are
sitting there thinking because my mind
is blown right now in that Maggie I
think nose flowers and plants so well
she could just make it up definitely the
opposite like I definitely don't know
them so I just make them up you can pick
up plants and they look fine looks like
a take a look at another piece as
everybody's mine is popping right now
she's using propane guys it exports to
Photoshop with layers intact really yeah
so how long does it take you to do one
of these no I would see the most average
piece I work on is around the 30 to 35
hour mark but but but that includes
sketching concept a mine ops whole
process finalized finalizing artwork
putting artwork into templates like
that's my most average project so this
was actually commissioned by procreate
which is the app I used to draw so this
was they had just come out with a bunch
of new teachers especially the grid tool
mm-hmm and I built this illustration for
them it was not meant to be a time-lapse
is just a final piece but I wanted to
add in that time-lapse component so this
one I also drew keeping in mind that it
was going to be shown so I tried to
really clearly show the steps I was
using where traditionally I may work
even some in some ways from like left to
right like I may just fill in like the
entire left side of something and then
slowly build it over but in this one I
really did like layer by layer by layer
just trying to provide a little clarity
so yeah I don't hand I don't play with
hand lettering your typography often I
mean I play typography a lot but I don't
usually fully craft it from start to
finish but this might I did
okay what are you doing now some playing
with the symmetry tools here um I always
draw fully line work before I add color
in and lately I've been kind of
expanding that a little bit and trying
to draw individual layer below
set so that I can use them in other
projects and kind of start building a
library of plants that I can layer just
take a little bit of the total manual
aspect out of drawing I feel like I've
got that opportunity working digitally
so a lot of my projects that I'm doing
now have like multi news pieces about
them mm-hmm and how long did this
project take you son was like 35 to 40
hours this one took a long time because
I was using a lot of tools for the first
time yeah just the lettering alone I
think it took like eight hours are using
a custom brush or something that's just
built in oh yeah I know I slightly like
ever-so-slightly have modified the in
app brushes but for the most part I like
my brushes to feel like a pen so I don't
really use anything that I could not
replicate by hand so like the pen tool
that I use is built to be pretty similar
to my favorite micron pen and then the
color brushes I use are basically just
like a fill brush and I just add a
little shade of shading over the top
like the actual tools themselves are
pretty simplistic mm-hmm and so what do
we do now recoloring yeah so on this one
I did each layer separately so that I
could try to get make sure I had some
color balance across and then I threw it
all together so it's kind of like
individually illustrating each colored
layer and then stacking them on top of
each other yeah it's just admire this
for a little bit guys mmm so is this
based on a serif typeface that we might
recognize I'm not sure no it feels a
little like Bower Bodoni with some iu
yeah I do a lot of but donees yeah yeah
like a modern sense or serif typeface
and then you get some flourishes with
the a you pulled it down there just kind
of scoop underneath both of you
I like that yeah it looks amazing to me
let's look at the third piece what are
we doing here just having fun this is a
brush it's like us it's the studio pen
brush that I slightly modified as well
we're usually tapers slightly at the end
yeah I took the paper out so is the
brush itself does it make that teardrop
shape and you're just drawing it all
right yeah I mean with it with a certain
amount
yes Wow so each one of these teardrop
shapes is a brush stroke right you just
pull it across
is there a mass that's holding back the
Jo Y or is it just you're just staying
within the line no so I had already
drawn the Jo I so I just did it in a
slightly different color and built
around it basically kind of cushioning a
little bit more every time but then
whatever color I'm working in say it's
I'm probably drawing red right now hmm
I would like kind of create a ring of
red and then leave the red into open
spaces and the colors before it so just
making sure everything's kind of evenly
distributed and usually I do that by
color coding so especially when I'm
working on a really complex piece yes
what I have like the same leaf woven in
through a pattern 20 times just in order
to make sure that I'm actually getting
an equal distribution I'll draw in a
completely different color so that I can
tell where I'm putting them whap it to
black and white like as I finish it okay
guys I think we're kind of at the tail
end of this you guys make sure you guys
follow at little patterns that's
Maggie's account that's Maggie into Rios
little patterns and calm and that's it
so Maggie thank you very much for coming
on the show guys thank you
[Applause]